what I have attempted to draw here in
yellow is a parabola and as we've
already seen in previous videos a
parabola can be defined as the set of
all points that are equidistant to a
point and a line and the point is called
the focus of the parabola and the line
is called the directrix of the parabola
what I want to do in this video it's
going to get a little bit of hairy
algebra but given that definition I want
to see and given that definition and
given a focus at the point x equals a y
equals b and a line of directrix at y
equals K to figure out what is the
equation of that parabola actually going
to be and it's going to be based on A's
B's and K's so let's do that so let's
take a arbitrary point on the parabola
let's say we take this point right over
here and its x-coordinate is X that it's
y-coordinate is y and by definition in
order for this to be a parabola it has
to be equidistant to its focus and its
directrix so what does that mean
that means that the distance to the
directrix which I'm drawing here in blue
has to be the same as the distance to
the focus which I am drawing in magenta
and when we take the distance to the
directrix we literally just drop a
perpendicular I guess you could say that
is the that's going to be the shortest
distance to that line and then when we
but the distance to the focus
well--that's we see that set a that's a
bit of an angle and we might have to use
the distance formula which is really
just the Pythagorean theorem so let's do
that this distance has to be the same as
that distance so what's this blue
distance well that's just going to be
our change in Y it's going to be this Y
it's going to be this Y minus K it's
just this distance so it's going to be Y
minus K now we have to be careful the
way I've just drawn it yes Y is greater
Y is greater than K so this is going to
give us a positive value and you need a
non-negative value if you're talking
about distances but there are you can
definitely have a parabola where the y
coordinate of the focus is lower than
the y coordinate of the directrix in
which case this would be negative so
what we really want is the absolute
value of this or you could say we
could square it and then we could take
the square root the principal root which
would be equivalent to taking the
absolute value of Y minus K so that's
this distance right over here and by the
definition of a parabola in order for X
comma Y to be sitting on the parabola
that distance needs to be the same as
the distance from X comma Y to a comma B
to the focus so what's that going to be
well we just apply the distance formula
or really just the Pythagorean theorem
it's going to be our change in X so X
minus a squared plus the change in Y Y
minus B squared and the square root of
that whole thing the square root of all
of that business now this right over
here is an equation of our parabola it
doesn't look like it it looks really
hairy but it is the equation of a
parabola and to show you that we just
have to simplify this and if you get
inspired I encourage you to try to
simplify this on your own is just going
to be a little bit of hairy algebra but
it really is not too bad you're going to
get an equation for a parabola that you
might recognize it's going to be in
terms of kind of a general focus a comma
B and a general directrix y equals K so
let's do that so the simplest thing is
to start here so let's just square both
sides so we get rid of the radicals so
if you square both sides on the left
hand side you're going to get Y minus K
squared you're going to get Y minus K
squared is equal to is equal to X minus
a squared plus y minus B plus y minus B
squared fair enough now what I want to
do is I just want to end up with just a
Y on the left hand side and just X is a
B's and KS on the right-hand side so the
first thing I might want to do is let's
expand each of these expressions that
involve with Y so this blue one on the
left hand side that is going to be
that's going to be Y squared minus 2y k
plus K squared and that is going to be
equal to I'm going to keep this first
one the same so it's going to be X minus
a squared and now let me expand let me
expand I'm going to find a color
expand this in green so plus y squared
minus 2y B plus B squared all it is I
multiplied y minus B times y minus B now
let's see if we can simplify things so I
have a Y squared on the Left I have a Y
squared on the right well if I subtract
Y squared from both sides so I can do
that well that simplifies things a
little bit and now I can I can let's see
what I can do
well let's get the K squared on this
side so let's subtract K squared from
both sides so subtract K squared
subtract K squared from both sides so
that's going to get rid of it on the
left hand side and now let's add 2y B to
both sides so we have all the Y's on the
left-hand side so plus 2y B that's going
to move this that's going to put us give
us a 2y be on the left-hand side plus 2y
B so what is this going to be equal to
and I'm trying to run into my graph so
let me give myself a little bit more
real estate over here so on the
left-hand side what am i going to have
this is the same thing as 2 y be -2 YK
which is the same thing actually let me
just write that down
that's going to be 2y do it in green G
well yeah why not green that's going to
be actually we start a new color that's
going to be 2y B minus 2 y K you can
focus you can factor out a 2 y and it's
going to be 2y times B minus K so let's
do that so we could write this as 2 or
we could write it 2 times B minus K Y if
you factor out a 2 and Y so that's the
left-hand side so that's that piece
right over there these these things
cancel out now on our right-hand side I
promised you a little bit of hairy
algebra so hopefully you see that I'm
delivering on that promise
on the right-hand side you have X minus
a squared and then let's see these
characters cancel out and you're left
with B squared minus K squared so these
two are going to be B squared minus K
squared plus B squared minus K squared
now I said all I want is Y on the left
hand side so let's divide everything by
two times B minus K so let's divide
everything times two times B minus K so
two times B minus K and I'm actually
going to divide this whole thing by two
times B minus K now what now obviously
on the left hand side this all cancels
out you're left with just a Y and then
it's going to be y equals y is equal to
one over two times B minus K and less B
minus K is the difference between the y
coordinate of the focus and the y
coordinate I guess you could say of the
line y equals K so it's one over two
times that times X minus a squared X
minus a squared so if you knew what B
minus K was R this would just simplify
to some number some number that's being
multiplied times X minus a squared so
hopefully this is starting to look like
the parabolas that you remember from
your childhood if you do remember
parabolas from your childhood all right
so then let's see if we could simplify
this thing on the right and you might
recognize B squared minus K squared
that's a difference of squares that's
the same thing as that's the same thing
as B plus K times B minus K times B
whoops times B minus K so the B minus K
is canceled out and we are just left
with and we deserve a little bit of a
drumroll we're just left with 1/2 times
B plus K so there you go given a focus
at the point a comma B and a directrix
at y equals K we now know what the
formula of the parabola is actually
going to be so for example so for
example if I had a focus if I had a
focus at the point I don't know let's
say the point 1 comma 2 and I had a
directrix
I had a directrix at why Y is equal to
and let's make it Y is equal to negative
1 what would the formula for what would
the equation of this parabola be well it
would be Y
equal to one over two times B minus K so
2 minus negative 1 that's the same thing
as 2 plus 1 so that's 2 times that's
just 3 2 minus negative 1 is 3 times X
minus times X minus 1 whoops X minus 1
squared plus 1/2 times B plus K 2 plus
negative 1 is 1 so 1 and so what's this
going to be you're going to get Y is
equal to 1 over 1/6 X minus 1 squared
plus 1/2 there you go
that is the parabola with a focus at 1
comma 2 and a directrix at y equals
negative 1
fascinating